do you think we have ideas or ideas have
us
I think that we're going to get super
scary memes once the AIS actually are
superhuman oh like if the AI will
generate memes of course you think it'll
make humans laugh
I think it's worse than that so
um Infinite Jest it's introduced in the
first 50 pages is about a tape that you
uh once you watch it once you only ever
want to watch that tape
um in fact you want to watch the tape so
much that someone says okay here's a
hacksaw cut off your pinky and then I'll
let you watch the tape again and you'll
do it uh so we're actually going to
build that I think but it's not going to
be one static tape I think the human
brain is too complex to be
stuck in one static tape like that if
you look at like ant brains maybe they
can be stuck on a static tape
but we're going to build that using
generative models we're going to build
the tick tock that you actually can't
look away from
so Tick Tock is already pretty close
there but the generation is done by
humans the algorithm is just doing their
recommendation but if it's if the
algorithm is also able to do the
generation
well it's a question about how much
intelligence is behind it right so the
content is being generated by let's say
one Humanity worth of intelligence and
you can quantify a Humanity right that's
a
you know it's it's
a flops yada flops uh but you can
quantify it once that generation is
being done by 100 Humanities you're done
so it's actually a scale that's the
problem
but also speed
yeah and what if it's sort of
manipulating
the very limited human dopamine engine
for porn
imagine just Tick Tock but for porn yeah
it's like a Brave New World
I don't even know what it'll look like
right like again you can't imagine the
behaviors of something smarter than you
but a super intelligent and and an agent
that just dominates your intelligence so
much will be able to completely
manipulate you is it possible that it
won't really manipulate it'll just move
past us it'll just kind of exist the way
water exists or the air exists you see
and that's the whole AI safety thing
not the machine that's going to do that
it's other humans using the machine that
are going to do that to you yeah because
the machine is not interested in hurting
humans it's just the machine is a
machine yeah but the human gets the
machine and there's a lot of humans out
there very interested in manipulating
you